where there was 22 a methodological one
were borrowed from Linus Pauling that
the most direct route to the structure
was building molecular models as opposed
to trying to deduce the structure
entirely from x-ray diffraction data
there was a decision that quick and I
made in October of 1951 the second was
the the realization that act that the
data of erwin chargaff showing similar
amounts of adding and thymine and
guanine and cytosine indicated that they
must be paired to each other in the DNA
structure once you had that in fact this
structure followed within several weeks
oh that every bedroom maybe the best
thing that ever happened to it was I
didn't find a date because that one I'm
you know the right girl I would have
found more interesting than you know yes
head cold play tennis or something yeah
I would have preferred doing that than
just you know thinking about DNA words
my great advantage was I was at the time
the only person truly obsessive about
DNA and you know you'll feel so many
people were just obsessive about someone
realized the you know emotional problem
so that Cambridge University really
everything they came with forest is
filled with you know well-dressed
attractive intelligent girls the the to
Cambridge colleges when I were there the
girls were out of town we diversity
never saw them and you know it was just
like it was for a later time in my life
well initially I wanted to you know move
on for the structure of DNA to RNA and
that didn't seem to fall so that was a
disappointment but on a whole because
everything he heard faster than we
thought it what that you know we had the
the genetic code the first details and
61 and his completion by 66 it was only
13 years and I would have thought it
could go so fast and then I never even
dreamed you know that we'll be able to
the sequence long stretches of DNA does
you would actually see the structure of
specific genes then we were largely
think in terms of small viruses because
we knew they contained only to several
dreams and so maybe the elder bug would
be to someday work out the structure of
the sequence or virus containing several
thousand letters but once it started it
just as moved you know with always you
know we had that the methods before we
almost had the questions asked about
what we were seeing